another escalation of tensions between
the u.s and china
trump took actions against china in
retaliation for its recent moves on hong
kong
he authorized sanctions on banks and
officials
involved in imposing a tough new
security law that effectively terminates
the semi-autonomous territories
unique status today i signed legislation
and an executive order to hold
china accountable for its oppressive
actions against the people of hong kong
we've all watched what happened not a
good situation
their freedom's been taken away their
rights have been taken away and with it
goes hong kong in my opinion
he made a statement today the u.s move
comes two weeks after beijing passed a
new law that many say represses
fundamental democratic freedoms in the
city
the law prohibits what beijing views as
subversive activities
and gives the police sweeping powers to
conduct searches and make arrests
something the authorities made ample use
of as soon as the law was passed
trump also revoked hong kong's special
trading
today status also signed an executive
order ending u.s preferential treatment
for hong kong
hong kong will now be treated the same
as mainland china
no special privileges no special
economic treatment
and no export of sensitive technologies
without its privileges hong kong could
lose its position as a bustling and
competitive financial hub
wiping out businesses and threatening
livelihoods
a lot of people will be leaving hong
kong i suspect
and we're going to do a lot more
business because of it because we just
lost one competitor
as the deep freeze between the two super
powers shows no signs of thawing hong
kong's residents are left
out in the cold let's cross over to
beijing now in our correspondent
matthias bilinga good morning to you
matthias how much pressure is this move
by washington
putting on the communist party in
beijing
well first of all it puts a lot of
pressure on the hong kong economy hong
kong's business model
was to be part of the international
community and
living by international business rules
but being closely aligned to china
now hong kong will have to redefine its
economic position
china seems to see it in the future more
like an
offshore location for chinese companies
chinese capital
started to flow into hong kong after the
national security law whereas
international businesses
are cautious so
the communist party seems to think that
it can manage this transition
and keep hong kong that way
the sanctions on individuals of the
communist party
of course will put pressure on some of
them the us
along with other western countries have
been a major destination for them to
send their
children to study xi jinping's own
daughter has studied in the us
so this might anger them but it will it
will not very likely change their course
matthias beijing has responded to the
move by promising retaliation
what do you think we can expect
well what beijing has done so far in
response to another act that is very
similar that also
targets individual uh stakeholders in
the chinese government
the xinjiang policy act was that they
have
issued similar sanctions on individual
u.s
politicians now this will not harm u.s
politicians in the same way u.s
politicians do not
send their children to study in china
they do not
travel frequently to china they also do
not bring
uh or their funds or their personal uh
assets into china so this is probably
not the most powerful tool that china
has china could of course retaliate
against
american businesses in china there are
various ways to do this to target them
with investigations
to uh change uh tariffs etc
and it might also um retaliate by
um uh not fulfilling its obligations
from the trade one phase deal so far
however this is not what we've seen
china has just announced
buying more agricultural goods from the
us
okay that certainly is a good signal but
what what about the broader context
where does this move leave u.s chinese
relations
chinese u.s relations are at a
historical low they have never
been as bad as they are now in the past
40 years
um and the fact that the two countries
might agree on selling some agricultural
products of course does not
speak to their ability to solve the
problems between them because these
problems their
various their trade problems uh that
have not been able to be
that that both sides have not been able
to tackle in
uh this uh in this agreement for example
talking about
high-tech cooperation etc their
strategic geostrategic and military
problems the south china sea for example
where china has extended its um
its reach into into this sea that is
boarded by several
nations in south east asia and the us
and also the international american
court have
renounced these claims by china
um there has been also uh quite a harsh
statement
just now also from the u.s foreign
ministry that says that china's claims
are illegal uh it reaches out to the
security of taiwan
which is de facto independent but
claimed by
china and where china is also ramping up
its
threats and it extends to a lot of the
international relations of china with
other nations
um like india for example that is driven
closer to the us so there's a vast
vast vast set of problems uh that both
sides seem not to be able to tackle at
the moment
not at all thanks a very much for that
matthias berlinger forestry
from beijing